Naya Rivera and David Spade pack on the  PDA poolside in Hawaii  [Music]  you heard that right the 30 year old  Glee star and the 52 year old comedian  were spotted getting cozy while swimming  in a hotel pool in Oahu absolutely Naya  and David seemed in great spirits  hugging and giggling during their Fun in  the Sun  David rocked a white wide-brimmed hat  and aviator shades while Naya rocked big  Sony's of her own a source tells ety  quote it's very casual and they had a  fun time together our source adds the  pair met through mutual friends and hung  out while they both were in Hawaii David  was there on his here come the funny  tour et spoke Naya in August where she  opened up about the type of men she's  into and it seems David would fit the  part yeah I like long hair like on away  boy  [Music]  you